[Music]
another two minutes of the game of
credits yes they do a good job of
establishing the places that'll be
referenced in the episode but seriously
I don't need a token map before every
episode this credit sequence inspired
the game of thrones lego sets here the
little finger bordello was sold out in
minutes
glad we got all that map out of the way
so we can focus on dammit
my granddaughter I'm Mary fine this show
doesn't get enough credit for how funny
it can be I haven't seen the rest of
this episode yet so I'm guessing when
people remember this one it's mainly
because it's so funny I can always see
what's going on beneath a dress up
skirting the wine will flow rate the
music will play loud and we'll put this
mess behind us my daily mantra somehow
makes it into an episode of Game of
Thrones I have no interest in slaves a
man cannot make love to property there
are very specific hardware fetish videos
on the internet that would beg to differ
well west of Castle black but the
nightfort's closest to us it was the
first castle on the wall I'm not saying
that this character development for Sam
isn't worthwhile but I am saying that I
didn't need a full minute of him
yammering on about wall details if I
wanted that I'd turn on fox news and
this baby never even moves or makes a
peep this baby is so fake that I'd swear
it was Bradley Cooper holding it you're
like who is it if being well-read makes
you a wizard then I'm well what's a few
steps below a wizard oh yeah I'm not a
wizard
many tykes what the hell helm you help
this guy fix his wagon and then kill him
I know we needed to see artis kindness
here but if you were going to kill him
why wait for that matter why even punch
him just stick him right away instead of
leading him on I get that the Hound is a
brute but you have to draw a line in the
sand or somewhere right what's one old
man doing with eight horses no one knows
but many believe Martin is working on a
spin-off series with this character he's
already started on the first book so
expected no later than 2046
are we suggesting that John knew if he
hit that rock with his sword that a
horse would startle from a hundred feet
away and then make the other horses
Restless enough that this old man would
not only hear it but immediately come
out to check this idea not only rests on
the most primitive Rube Goldberg device
ever but anyone who has neighbors with
dogs knows it also severely
underestimates how lazy humans are some
day I'm gonna put salty rye and out the
back of your skull course shadowing I'll
take anything that will put an end to
this F story gal Fox and the Hound make
him shut Tommy to be fair all of you are
speaking as loud as he is I heard
shouting up there Thunder right because
arguing about easily verifiable facts
makes more sense than you know sending
someone up to check what is this Twitter
stopped us in the back first chance he
gets
but isn't that what the wildling does as
well is there some lore about not
striking a bird with your sword because
for the life of me I can't figure out
why snowflake here isn't even taking a
swing at up before it attacks Birdemic
three quo versus crow show has us the
audacity to convenience bran and John to
the exact same place and then he rides
off without even knowing show doesn't
even know how to convenience properly
I'm a great Whistler racist in know that
they might as well just name this
character weird flex mikake pops you got
inside how do those mine I can't do that
muscle
no I feel the entirety of Westeros needs
to be educated on scanners immediately
I'm coming with you I'm coming with you
cliche keep this one safe in the world
to me that's why I'm leaving him in the
middle of the night with a couple of
kids and Hodor to protect him holy [ __ ]
that will champion from Coldplay to do
the reception this is gonna be lit also
can they play viva la vida I love the
part where it says one minute I held the
key next the walls were closed on me and
I discovered that my castles stand upon
pillars of salt and pillars of sand not
sure how that applies to the situation
but it's a great jail I need to find a
tree to piss on that's arborist yeah man
and wife a sword needs a sheath father
of the bride three jokes about my
daughter's lady bits don't you want to
teach little Ned Stark how to ride
horses oh these two were the best I
can't wait to watch them raise wait why
is that guy closing the door I'm sure
it's nothing to worry about the bands
playing the cool song about how the
Lannisters have literate their enemies
so
why does count 1 look worrying wait his
bomb wearing chainmail why would he be
wearing oh my god is he going what is
happening problem survived yeah this is
really happening
but Arya will at least save all those
moments will be lost time like tears
aslam is on the move you roll the dice
to move your token doubles gets another
turn and the first player to reach in
wins how do you know all that I have
many leather-bound books
[Music]
do it do it just do it
[Music]
look upon each other and say the words
shamble bobble Dibble dooble